You may remember from physics or
somewhere else, that if I've got some
point that's at a vector R from
the origin, let's say I'm the origin or
the origin is the middle of the object,
doesn't matter.
If that point is rotating about
the origin with some angular rotational
omega, and it's also translating with
some translational velocity T, okay?
The overall velocity of that point,
I hope you remember this from physics,
was V is equal to omega cross R plus T.
It's just true, you can work it out.
And, here's what that
looks like written out.
You remember we did that crossing
operator could be written as a matrix
multiplication.
We did that for essential and
fundamental matrices,
so that's all this is.
We've just written out
the cross operator as a matrix
where these are the components of the,
of rotational velocity, and
these are the components of
the translational velocity.
In fact, that's what it says here,
so VX, V sub X, V sub Y, V sub Z,
are the velocity vectors.
In the world, in the world,
in the XYZ direction, VTX, VTY,
VTZ are the translational components
in the world and omega X, omega Y, and
omega Z are the angular velocity
components in the world, all right?